Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in the book of
purification of Alwaji, the chapter
regarding the
preferred Third instances
in which we are taught by the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam to bathe
the preferred
instances when a person is encouraged
to bathe and we've mentioned two thus
far. Number one, he mentions bathing
after every
encounter
or after every
time a person has relations with
his
wife or with her husband for a person to
bathe. if they wish to do this again
to bathe as well. This is and we
discussed this yesterday. The second is
as we mentioned yesterday
is a woman a female who has
a medical issue where her menstrual
cycle has finished. It is completed.
However, blood continues to come out
of her private parts
even after her
menstrual cycle has concluded and the
blood is a different shade. It's very
different type of blood. It's very
known. It's well known and it is bright
red bleeding or close to that as is
mentioned in the books of f and so a
person this her menstrual cycle is
completed. So she is to bathe and pray.
However, this blood continues to come
out and so she has the ruling of al-
is this kind of instance and this goes
for any person and this is usually what
falls in the books of into the chapters
regarding
or the books regarding
that is someone whom the their they
have a medical issue in which their body
continues to do what would otherwise
break a person's woo whether that be gas
whether that be urine whether that be
in this instance you know bleeding
etc and so what is she to do well it's
permissible posible
and the the least that she is to do is
to make woo for each salah.
However, the best thing to do is to
bathe for each salah, right? And
depending on how long this is the lasts,
this could be more or less practical and
suited for her particular situation.
for
[Silence]
Hadith.
Oh,
Fore.
[Silence]
So here we have a narration on the
authority of
who narrates that a woman by the
had this issue of
during the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's epic and the prophet
sallallah.aii Wasam commanded her to
make
for each
salah. Now we will come to realize later
that this is the highest level,
right? Because he commands her to make
for each salah. However, later when we
get to the chapter regarding, we'll see
that the minimum is that she make wudoo
for each salah. And this chapter's
purpose is merely to mention the times
when it is preferred that a person
bathe. in another wording of this
same narration, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
commanded her to
make
earlier
and to delay
later. Now notice very closely the
wording here.
[Silence]
Yakunu walked
yakun
[Silence]
So here we have something very curious.
We have to pay attention to this and
that is is this when he says to delay
and hasten.
So to bathe and then delay and hasten.
He says and then to bathe and delay and
hasten
and then to make for this is what he
tells her. Now is this joining the
prayers?
Why not?
So when we join the prayers, we remember
we talked about this before. Before the
five daily prayers were made, five daily
prayers. How many prayers were there?
Three. Remember there were three. There
was
the time, the daytime prayer, the
nighttime prayer, the time, and the
prayer. There were three prayers on the
night of and they were all what how many
two except for
was always three but everything else was
twoish
tells us this is how was before.
Then he went on
and the prayers were made five
and the resident was made to pray the
two into four except for
and that it stayed the same for the
traveler.
Notice the wording that that uses and it
remained the same for the traveler.
So when we say it remained the same for
the traveler that means that the
traveler has three times of salah
and it is at each except for
soar
when we join those two prayers for any
reason for any reason whether it's
illness fear war whatever there's many
reasons a person can join the prayers
The two prayers of the day are joined
together and the two prayers of the
night are joined together. We don't ever
join the day and night prayers together.
Correct? So we don't pray we don't join
for instance and we don't join and for
instance and we don't join
for instance because we have daytime
prayers we have nighttime prayers and
then we have fud. Now understanding this
when a person travels those five prayers
now become three again and vhar's time
and's time are joined into one long
time. So a person has to make and from
the start of till the end of and the
person has from the beginning of to the
end of
and the time for never changes. This is
how we join prayers. So let's say it is
raining very hard in a way that makes it
you know dangerous or very difficult to
come to the masid and so we join the
prayers because of rain let's say this
is something that I haven't seen here
have you guys do you guys have you ever
done this before here because the rain
here in the desert is usually you
know pretty fairly sporadic. It's not
continuous. But in other places, other
regions, it can snow very hard. It can
it can ice up the roads, etc. Even with
our modern concrete and our modern
four-wheel drives, and it is not only
difficult to come to the masjid, but
hazardous. And so, we join the prayers.
So, when we join the prayers, we join
either early or late. So we make
we make in the time of with it or we
make after its time in the beginning
time of this is how we would join it. We
make in time or we make at's time
correct
now in this narration
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
told her to delay
and to hasten
and to delay
and hasten.
The scholars have understood this
narration in two different ways.
Some say
this is actually
joining
it it appears to be joining but it's
actually not joining prayers.
So the idea is you make at its very last
minute
by that time when you finish's
time is in then you make right away and
then you wait for until it's just the
last few minutes you make and then by
the time you're finished it's so you
make
but let me ask you a Question. What is
the purpose of joining prayers?
We all know. Huh?
Yeah. Right. To make it easy. Is it
easier to just pray the prayers on time
or to wait till the last second and then
time your prayer? Which one is more
difficult? Which one demands more
vigilance?
The second type. Then
that's not how this narration should be
understood and that's the opinion of the
majority of the scholars and the form
is that no the wording of the narration
is curious. However, this is merely
joining the prayers for someone who is
experiencing an illness. And we will
discuss this in the chapter that is
specified for this which is
these chapters are specifically for this
issue and we will discuss this issue
inshallah when we arrive at it. But a
woman who has this, she may join her
prayers.
[Silence]
Oh yeah. How you doing this time? All
right.
How you doing? How are things?
Better.